m
[Musique]
cyrus est le nom de ce programme
scientifique international dans lequel
s'inscrit cette expérience si personne
cosmonautes ingénieurs médecins vont
embarquer pour une simulation de voyage
aller retour vers la lune longue de huit
mois et ce afin d'apprendre à vivre et
travailler dans l'espace
sans malgorn panier
qui n'est ball est effective n'est le
plus important est de comprendre quelles
sont les méthodes de formation à
distance les plus efficaces permettant
aux astronautes d'effectuer des vols
spatiaux à long terme à l'avenir
d'améliorer leurs connaissances de les
entretenir et de pouvoir exécuter des
tâches de manière efficace à grande
distance de la terre pour moi c'est
peut-être un rêve en quelque sorte le
rêve est de voler dans l'espace en
restant sur terre puis mois selon les
standards terrestre c'est peut-être
beaucoup et lorsque vous planifiez ce
que vous avez à accomplir pendant ce
temps vous vous rendez compte que c'est
une période assez courte
et c'est un équipage mixte
internationale au profil différent qui
va participer à cette expérience
pour autant que je sache à ce stade il
devrait y avoir trois russes deux
américains et un participants des
émirats arabes unis ce sera 50 50 femmes
hommes nous aurons un commandant un
mécanicien navigant un chirurgien
d'équipage et trois spécialistes de
mission nous apportons tous quelque
chose de très unique et nous rassemblons
différents parcours éducatifs culturels
professionnels différentes expériences
personnelles à mon avis la composition
de l'équipage tel qu'il a été
sélectionné est très bonne nous sommes
vraiment complémentaires les uns
vis-à-vis des autres
c'est bien beau de toujours vouloir
aller plus loin et plus longtemps dans
l'espace mais encore faut-il y vivre
dans de bonnes conditions
huit mois 240 jours dans un espace
restreint a forcément des conséquences
sur le corps humain il a donc fallu
élaborer des protocoles les instruments
des machines pour entretenir l'état de
forme des participants
lorsqu'ils sont en isolement la
monotonie est un problème en faisant le
même entraînement durant huit mois on se
lasse vite
donc nous devons distincts nouveau
protocole d'entraînement ensuite nous
avons un jeu légèrement différent ici
avant l'expérience duré cinq cents jours
mission vers mars maintenant nous volons
vers la lune par conséquent nous avons
une durée d'isolement différentes et
détache légèrement différente
dans le cadre de notre expérience nous
effectuons un test d'effort pour estimer
les capacités et la cinétique de la
performance physique on regarde donc la
performance physique et aussi
l'interaction entre la performance
physique et la performance cognitive
[Musique]
enfermés dans un module qui ressemble un
vaisseau spatial coupés du monde pendant
de longs mois les participants à ce
programme vont donc étudier tous les
aspects de la vie confinée
et c'est grâce à ce genre de programme
qu on voyagera à l'avenir dans l'espace
dans les meilleures conditions possibles